One two three four.
We call it blending.
If you're blending right you can't pick out any individual voices but the soloist.
My name is Izzy Lloyd.
I am a mechanical engineering and product design student at MIT
and I'm an alto in the MIT Corallaries.
[singing]
I joined Freshman Fall, so Fall of 2014.
I am now the old crusty senior.
These kinds of things are like truly the definition of like, "The whole is greater than the sum of the parts".
[singing]
Thank you all so much for coming out!
We're the Corallaries of MIT, MIT's oldest co-ed acapella group.
We invited you all to attend our concert tomorrow at 3:30 p.m. in Kresge Auditorium.
[singing]
This is a dedicated time where I just get to turn my brain off to engineering
and turn it onto art.
We are a very highly sought after group in terms of gigs.
A of the times charity functions will have us, Institute events will have us a lot.
And the money goes towards like recording albums, going on tour, competing in competitions.
"We all get in formation for the next song while Caitlyn announces us..."
It's hard when we step out of MIT.
Because you've got all of these other brilliant acapella groups across the world
who, the best ones, are made up of students who like, their major is music.
Welcome to the Corallaries of MIT presenting "Game of Tones!"
We are so excited to have you all here in great big Kresge Auditorium!
[audience cheering]
[singing]
Being able to step into this space where
we all create this beautiful thing together
just like totally resets sort of the way I'm thinking and the way I'm feeling.
[audience cheering]